[Musique]
on peut vivre sans les choses
facebook
ce des seniors étaient présents
[Musique]
c
le départ nous non
on ne la bohème
on peut vivre sans l'ado rockets
être reconnu dans l'histoire
et nous
vb les livres sont ouverts sur des
questions non
est-ce que
quel tous les vols quelle jolie
sentiment ce besoin de tendresse que
nous vient tourner sans vraiment
m
c'est dans le feu de l'avenir
et la mouffette épouse
ça pour nous et blues
oui mais son auto
non
l'amour
un enfant nous sentons pas ce qu'on leur
enlever tous nos chagrins ses frères
là
[Musique]
en fait non plus par son sort
c'est pas glamour là
vous
jusqu'à la fin
et je ne
[Musique]